if you've ever skied on a mountain  covered in artificial snow you have a  microbe to thank to make snow ski  resorts use a protein ina Z from a  bacteria that in nature damages plants  by jump-starting the freezing process  inside leaves to better understand this  freezing power researchers used a  special laser based spectroscopy  technique they found that I use e  arranges water molecules into the right  formation to create ice and it also  aligns water into alternating tightly  packed and loosely packed stripes ice is  more likely to form at the line where  those stripes meet the protein plus the  protein funnels heat away from water as  it freezes helping the process along  since the microbes also contribute to  the production of snow and rain in the  atmosphere understanding more about the  bacteria's icy abilities could help  researchers make better predictions  about climate change